Most amazing things happen when you say
yes to God.
The most unexpected things happen when
you say yes to God.
Somebody asked me if I could boil down
all of my Christian faith into one word,
and that word for me is,
I thought about it was the word
surrender or just in really simple
terms,
it's,
it's saying yes to God.
It's saying that,
um,
I believe God that you probably know
what's best from our life for my life,
more than I do.
And I'm willing to trust you with my
life and I'm willing to go along with
what I understand to be your plans for
my life.
And in so doing it,
it causes you to have to say no to
yourself.
Because honestly what gets in my way
every day is myself.
I call it in the book the Kingdom of me,
that to be really honest,
the person I love the most is myself and
that I like most people and eager to
make the world revolve around me.
I want my comfort,
my convenience.
I want you to see life from my point of
view.
I want you to think I'm right.
I want you to like the way I do things.
So it's we're pretty self centered
creatures,
all of us.
And to say yes to God means in many ways
saying no to myself.
For instance,
in I'm a real practical way that I can
think of that is in,
in a marriage.
Um,
my husband and I both are self centered
people.
We are,
we love ourselves more than even we love
each other unfortunately.
And sometimes in an argument or a
potential argument,
I will want him to look at life through
my set of lenses.
I want him to see a situation from my
point of view.
And if he doesn't,
it's really easy to get offended,
to get wounded,
to get hurt,
to get bitter,
to surrender to God is to take that same
kind of analogy that I'm saying in
marriage of saying to my husband,
I can either fight for all my ways,
my thoughts,
my agenda,
my dreams,
and kind of run over his,
or I can many times kind of just go
along with his will on a,
on a bigger scale.
That's what it means to say yes to God.
There is my way of doing things,
which frequently involves jealousy,
you know,
bitterness,
anger,
greed.
All of those things are not God's ways.
Those don't,
those don't come from God.
So when I'm saying Yes to God,
I'm choosing his way,
I'm choosing a response that's really
more like something he would choose,
which would be love,
compassion,
mercy,
grace,
tenderness,
giving people second chances.
Those are all the things that come more
from a heart of God.
Then the ones that come from my heart.